[Music]
hmm oh hello there welcome to the point
as you can see it's completely [__]
mental here right now at were in the
process of moving floors from the third
floor to the first floor of this
wonderful building at the game awards
are starting in about an hour's time
PlayStation experiences on this weekend
as well and on top of all of that this
morning we finished what feels like
weeks of discussions and wrapped up our
top 25 games of 2015 we have a top 25
list of what we think are the best games
that came out in 2015 a bunch of top
fives for each platform plus some
honorable mentions but these awards only
allow us to celebrate the great games
they came at this calendar year and
video games are about much more than
that what about all the smaller games
that push things forward a little bit
games that sucked last year but got
better in 2015 and games that are just
so [__] that they deserve a medal a
metal made of [__] so today on the point
we're going to honor some of those very
achievements welcome to the 2015
alternative game of the year awards
but like the Buddha best assassins creed
game grow home Ubisoft finally figured
out how to fix the Assassin's Creed
franchise it's not HD environments or
complex multi-character stories it's
just a climbing game which requires you
to actually [__] climb grow home may
be short but I had a more fun palms
sweaty time exploring the vertical
heights of this wonderful plant that I
did in all the hours exploring London
and Assassin's Creed syndicate it's a
folks on Steam go pick it up best
first-person shooter that didn't
technically come out god damn it i
really loved Unreal Tournament
especially all the dumb Halloween stuff
that they did but the real answer to
this one is over watch that game is
super the game modes themselves might be
tries but the character abilities in
level design lends itself to the type of
strategic diversity we only usually see
in MOBAs it's amazing fun to play around
with all the characters and explore the
levels I think when my game released
next year it's gonna be huge best [__]
game that got good because of its dlc
destiny my good friend destiny it turns
out all destiny needed to make good on
its original promise was over a hundred
dollars worth of expansion packs okay
granted you can buy all of it for like
60 bucks now and from the sound of all
the Destiny players in the office it's
pretty great but it still deserve
special recognition that this game
didn't really become the game they
promised until they sold a bunch of DLC
in any case the Destiny machine keeps on
gaining speed so don't stop pulling
those slot machines yet kids every time
you spend 50 hours in the game
Activision buys itself another mobile
games company game release which most
resembled a dumpster fire it's Batman
Arkham nice Jesus Christ Warner the pc
game was broken on a variety machines
launched then they pulled it from
shelves they put months of work into
patching it and then they launched it
again and it was still broken and now
the company is thrown in the towel so
much they're straight up just offering
refunds I don't think anyone thought the
master chief collection or Assassin's
Creed unity could be topped last year
but there you go looking forward to more
Buster releases in 2016 most objectified
woman wow it's been another bumper year
for games that depict women as objects
but nobody quite when is far and
objectifying the fairer sex as Hideo
Kojima and medal
solid five I mean a half naked model
with massive tits who spends most of the
game looking hard and saying absolutely
nothing kind of hard to beat and before
you all freaked out and say but he was
trying to say something man and she
doesn't talk for a reason in the game's
narrative just imagine for a second
while playing that game must have been
like for so many women the only female
character in the game stupidly fancy
tits lost it over by the main character
and doesn't talk Hideo Kojima has made
an amazing game in Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain but this manner of
brutally blatant female objectification
has absolutely no place in 2015 let's
hope at the very least we leave it there
longest game title Dragon Quest heroes
the world's trees woes and the bright
below at 62 characters most generic game
title The Legend of legacy hardest game
to pronounce mushy mushy mom mushi mushi
mushi ahem Mishima mushy mushy mushroom
another most disappointing game though
if you really take a minute to be honest
with ourselves we saw it coming
best non game disc to play in your
console Mad Max the movie adaptation of
codemasters 2009 open world racing game
fuel is really great you can buy it on
blu-ray for your PlayStation 4 or Xbox
one right now you don't even have to use
the controller allowing you the freedom
to eat snacks juggle and hug your cats
biggest buyers remorse I mean I like my
pitboy edition because it's the dumbest
peripheral since that tony hawk ride
board but it's fair to say that this
plastic piece of junk is less sturdy
than we all expected and it's basically
useless when playing the game but
whatever it'll be another seven years
before we play a new fallout and it
looks kind of nice on my shelf at all so
I guess the real answer is that xbox
controller game that we will hopefully
never see a sequel to hatred yeah
remember that I mean as bad as a
reception that game got back in June I
can't imagine they'd bother putting
another one of those games out in light
of recent international events but
hopefully 2015 was the last we've seen
of this postal clone most disappointing
delay I told you no man's sky wouldn't
come out this year but none you believe
me anyway the real answer is l don the
wii u who knows maybe we'll see it on
the NX in 2016 and don't worry ex-con to
fans you don't have that long to wait
until februari so those are my
alternative awards for 2015 but what's
the real game 'dear well make sure to
check back on gamespot com thursday
december 17 when we start counting down
our top 25 video games of the year one
will be at number one let us know what
you think in the comments below